[Music]
jennifer walters is an attorney who has
accidentally taken in the hoax blood
and has become like a shake hole a
she-hulk exactly
[Music]
that's got a nice ring to it that name
better not stick
there's something so surreal and so
funny about a giant six foot seven hulk
in the courtroom
it was about putting a real human being
into these absurd situations
it's just like as cool and edgy as we
can get away with girl your ass looks
crazy right now
it's something that you think you knew
which is law shows
and something that you think you know
which is marvel shows smash together
this show is so much fun it all has this
tongue-in-cheek self-referential thing
going on in the comics she broke the
fourth wall and was super meta
i just want to make sure that you don't
think this is one of those cameo every
week type of shows well except bruce
and blonsky
[Applause]
she spent all this time becoming a
lawyer and this idea of being a
superhero
is not appealing to her
being a superhero is a trial by fire
oh i'm not a superhero i just want to be
a normal anonymous lawyer there is no
going back to what you were before
who's going to protect the world
if not people like you
this is expanding the definition of what
a moral studio's production can be
this is a radical revolutionary show can
we get some shots please it's an
emergency
[Music]
wow jesus what the hell man still in
control no overwhelming feelings of rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert
back to gen 4 when you sleep was the air
horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on
yeah who's your best friend nikki
spandex spandex is your best friend
being a hulk asks for balance
you have so much more to learn
yes
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
if you want to go back to life as a
lawyer i i respect that
he doesn't mean that
more and more eccentric superhumans are
coming out of the woodwork
we are going to launch a division for
them and i want the she-hulk to be the
face of
jennifer wallace
namaste
i have a serious conflict of interest
this man tried to kill my cousin bruce
yeah that's quite all right oh
people only care because i'm
representing emil bonski i think they
care cause they're like hey that girl's
green
do your thing god i really like this
outfit
i'm not proud of this
miss walters we answered to a higher
power our universe is on the edge of a
precipice
i am a lawyer
we do things by the book
the book of the shanty no the book of
american
uh laws
whether you like it or not you're now a
superhero let's do this
you know that friend you had in high
school
who was way cooler than you were
attractive got all the attention from
everyone
hello
i think i'm jealous is that what i'm
feeling
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye